Dale Kaczmarek believes in ghosts...
...and he has been the president of the Ghost Research Society since 1982.
In his career, Kaczmarek has met many people who do not believe in ghosts...
...and when they find out he is a ghost expert, they think he is a fool.
So, one of Kaczmarek's goals is to make ghost research more scientific.
Not all people believe in ghosts, but most people trust science.
So, if ghost research becomes scientific, more people will respect Kaczmarek's work.
Kaczmarek follows a careful process to investigate ghosts.
The first step happens when someone telephones Kaczmarek about a ghost.
During the first phone call,...
...Kaczmarek interviews the caller to determine if it is a serious case or a hoax.
Next, Kaczmarek asks the caller what he or she wants him to do.
Some people want him to find out the cause of the paranormal activity,...
...while other people want him to remove a ghost from their house.
After the phone call,...
...Kaczmarek contacts other members of the Ghost Research Society...
...and Kaczmarek makes a team from a few members.
They visit the house where the ghost was reported,...
...but he never tells the members any details about the case.
This is very important to keep the investigation objective...
...because if they know the details, they might imagine seeing something.
After a thorough inspection of the location, the team talks to the homeowner...
...and they share what they have observed with each other for the first time.
By waiting until this time to share the details,...
...Kaczmarek believes that his method of investigation is more scientific.
Kaczmarek has shared his expertise of ghosts by writing books and giving tours of haunted places.
Kaczmarek wrote a book called "Windy City Ghosts" about ghosts in Chicago.
One of the stories in this book is about ghost horses and their ghost riders.
People sometimes see these ghosts on 95th Street,...
...which is a busy street that runs through the forest near some horse stables.
People ride horses from these stables into the forest and they must cross 95th Street.
Over the years, there have been several accidents...
...in which horses and riders were killed by fast-moving cars.
Sometimes at night, people driving through the forest...
...report seeing transparent horses and riders crossing the street.
They stop their cars to let the horses and riders pass,...
...but when they look closely, the horses and riders have disappeared!
All of these reports have come from the area where the horse trail crosses 95th Street.
Kaczmarek gives tours to this location and tries to explain the world of ghost research to his guests.
Through his books, tours, and the scientific process of his investigations,...
...Kaczmarek is improving the reputation of ghost researchers.